C'est vraiment dégueulasse ... hein ?
Jean louis était dans la boîte depuis combien de temps ?
- 20 ans !
20 ans ans de boite il le vire et il le remplace par un....
Mais qu'est-ce tu veux, les mecs ils bossent pour un rien ils font des heures supp' pas payé
Ils vont même pas à l'église le dimanche, les gars...
T'es vraiment une grosse ...
CHHHHHHHUT !!
Bonjour.
- Attention moi j'ai rien contre les pokémons
A condition qu'ils restent chez eux hein.
Parce que quand ils viennent en France , pour piquer les allocations familiales
Pika, Pika, Pikallocations familiales
Même pas foutu de parler français
Mon travail a peu de perspective d'évolution mais, j'ai des collègues sympas, alors ça compense.
Moi je ne veux pas de Pokémon chez moi
Ils répètent en boucle " on n'est pas des voleurs "" on n'est pas des voleurs
N'empêche que quand y a des voitures qui sont brulées , C'EST LES POKEMON !
Mais ceux qui vivent avec des Pokemon de toute façon c'est par intérêt
J'ai quelque amis dresseurs de pokemon j'peux vous dire ils le vivent bien, très bien
Hein ils roulent pas en Kangoo les gars quoi.
Eh ben c'est à cette heure la que tu rentres ? T'as traîné en chemin encore hein ?
Ben non, je rentre à pied puisque j'ai pas de vélo.
Nan mais ça je veux pas le savoir tu sais qu'y a match ce soir ? Tu sais aussi que t'as pas de papiers ?
Donc tu continue comme ça mon bonhomme ben c'est quoi ? Bah c'est charter pour Bourg-Palette direct'
- Pikachu...
Pika c'est l'heure du juste prix là fous-moi l’électricité
Maître Sacha est bien gentil de me laisser vivre chez lui et d'aller au travail à sa place.
Surtout que je suis un Pokemon sans papiers.
Bien sur qu'on a besoin des pokemon dans les années 90
Mais là c'est bon, ils peuvent rentrer chez eux
On se sent pas en sécurité avec eux
Toujours à se battre
"Salameeeeeeche" et tout c'est bon la
Moi j'ai peur
Pas comme la semaine dernière cette fois tu gagnes ! Parce que j'ai déjà perdu tous mes badges à cause de toi !
Alors pika-pika?
- Pika-pika!
Voila ça c'est mon champion !
- Pika-pika!!
Allez ta gueule vas-y.
- Utilise Coup de queue!
- Utilise pistolet a eau
Oui, les combats, c'est dégradant. Mais c'est toujours mieux que la prostitution...
Coupez! Coupez la caméra!Coupez!
C'est un squat de pokemon sans papier
( bruit de pokemon inconnu )
Attrapez les tous!!!
Hé moi là j'en ai chopé hein là. Il n'a pas de papiers. Et je ne le connais pas !
-enfoiré !
- Et c'est pas le mien
Pikachu a été expulsé et renvoyé à Bourg Palette.
Sacha a été condamné à 3 ans de prison. L'enquête a également montré qu'il prostituait depuis 5 ans des lippoutous.
ATTRAPEZ LES TOUS !!!
Abonne toi à la chaine !
Et si tu veux en voir plus,
Clique sur la vidéo Bonus avec Oldelaf en Roudoudou